GREG: YOU GOT THAT RIGHT.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: DO YOU REMEMBER
GREG: DO YOU REMEMBER 1969 WEST
MARK I DO SOME CALL IT THE GOOD
OLD DAYS BUT I DON'T.
IT SUCKED.
DOW JONES WAS AT 800 AND THE
AVERAGE INCOME A YEAR WAS UNDER
NINE GRAND AND SOMETHING CALLED
WOODSTOCK TOOK PLACE.
LOOK AT THESE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW THEY SMELL BAD.
LIKE A FISH IS JOCKSTRAP.
[LAUGHTER]
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY WERE THEM
BUT THEY COULD.
WHAT ALSO STUNK WAS FASHION.
PEOPLE ACTUALLY WORE THE STUFF
OUTSIDE AND THEY WERE TO PELTED
WITH HOT GARBAGE.
BASICALLY, THE WORLD REEKED BUT
I COULDN'T DO A THING.
I WAS FIVE YEARS OLD AND HERE IS
A PICTURE.
[LAUGHTER]
I WAS ADORABLE.
BUT I COULD DO NOTHING TO MAKE
THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE SO
INSTEAD I ATE AS MUCH PLATO AS
POSSIBLE.
THE POINT IS 1969 WAS A LONG
TIME AGO, 49 YEARS AGO AND YOU
HAVE TO GO BACK THAT FAR TO FIND
JOBLESS NUMBERS THAT ARE THIS
GOOD TODAY.
IT'S TRUE, APPLICATIONS FOR
UNAPPOINTED BENEFITS ARE NOW AT
A 49 YEAR LOW.
THAT'S ALMOST FIVE DECADES LONG
OF WHAT I CALL ONE EPISODE OF
THE VIEW.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
EASY JOKE.
TRUMP JOB NUMBERS ARE SO GOOD
THAT TO MATCH IT YOU HAVE TO GO
BACK TO AN ERA WHEN NOT BATHING
WAS CONSIDERED AN ACHIEVEMENT.
THAT IS WHAT WE CALLED THE NEWS
AND HUMANS LIKE GOOD NEWS BUT
NOT ALL HUMANS.
>> HE JUST TWEETED THEY ARE
MEETING IN SINGAPORE ON JUNE 12
AND THEY WILL BOTH TRY TO MAKE A
SPECIAL MOMENT FOR WORLD PEACE.
>> GOOD FOR HIM.
IF IT WORKS, WERE HAPPY FOR HIM.
GREG: YOU COULD JUST FEEL JOY'S
PAIN WHEN SHE SAID THAT.
IT'S LIKE SHE REALIZED THAT
WASN'T A PART.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF HUMANS
THAT DON'T LIKE GOOD NEWS.
THEY ARE CALLED WET BLANKETS.
>> THEIR RELEASE SHOULD NOT BE
EXALTED BUT EXPECTED.
IT IS NO GREATER ACCOMPLISHMENT
OF KIM JONG-UN TO DO THIS.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT DOES IT HE
WEAKENS AMERICAN FOREIGN-POLICY
AND PUTS AMERICANS AT RISK
AROUND THE WORLD.
GREG: TALK ABOUT THE OPPOSITE OF
FUN.
TO HIM THE GLASS IS HALF EMPTY
MUCH LIKE HIS SKULL.
[LAUGHTER]
SO, HERE WE HAVE GREAT NEWS BUT
MANY POLITICIANS IN MEDIA HACKS
ALL THEY SEE IS BAD.
IF ONLY THERE WERE A DRUG TO
HELP THEM.
>> UNEMPLOYMENT HIT 3.9% WHICH
IS GOOD NEWS FOR THE AMERICAN
WORKER.
COALITION FORCES ARE SET TO
DELIVER A FATAL BLOW TO ISIS.
>> THIS IS NOT GOOD.
>> YOU SHOULD TALK TO YOUR
DOCTOR.
YOU MAY BE SUFFERING FROM WBS.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> WBS STANDS FOR WHAT BLANKET
SYNDROME.
ANYTHING THAT HAPPENS YOU SEE IT
IS BAD NEWS.
NEWS ANCHORS GET IT ALL THE
TIME.
>> THREE AMERICAN HOSTAGES IN
SOUTH KOREA ARE BEING SENT HOME
RIGHT NOW
RIGHT NOW.
>> THERE IS NO CURE.
BUT YOU LIVE WITH IT.
IT TRICKS YOUR BRAIN INTO
THINKING EVERY DAY IS THE DAY
BEFORE A THREE-DAY WEEKEND
MAKING IT VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR YOU TO BE NOTHING BUT HAPPY
ALL THE TIME.
>> UNEMPLOYMENT AS IT LASTED 17
YEARS AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
DESERVES THE CREDIT.
>> WE ARE CLEAR.
>> THAT WEEK WENT FAST.
TIME FOR THREE DAYS OF FUN IN
THE SUN BUT HERE COMES THE
BEACH.
>> DUDE, IT IS ONLY WEDNESDAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OF ACADEMY, KEVIN.
>> DUDE, WHAT THE [BLEEP] IS HE
ON?
>> GET IT TODAY.
YOUR COWORKERS WILL GET IT BUT
WE DO.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: EVERY DAY IS THE DAY
BEFORE A THREE-DAY WEEKEND.
THAT IS SOME REALLY SURREAL
[BLEEP].
OKAY.
BACK TO THE REAL GOOD NEWS.
WASN'T JUST HUMAN VICTORY BETTER
RATINGS 12.
>> IT'S VERY EARLY IN THE
MORNING.
I THANK YOU PROBABLY BROKE THE
ALL-TIME IN HISTORY TELEVISION
RATINGS FOR 3:00 O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING.
THAT HE DID THIS AT 3:00 A.M.
IT COULD'VE BEEN ANY OTHER TIME
BUT HE CHOSE BEEN?
WHY TO TELL YOU THAT HE'S ALWAYS
UP.
HE IS ALWAYS UP FOR US AT EVERY
HOUR AND IF YOU HAD HILLARY
INSTEAD SHE WOULD ALREADY BE OUT
LIKE A BROKEN HEADLIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKING OF HILLARY, IF SHE WERE
PRESIDENT AND HAD A WEEK LIKE
TRUMP HOW MIGHT THE PRESS REACT?
GREG: BUT INSTEAD, WITH TRUMP
YOU GET THIS.
GREG: WHICH IS WHY HE HAD TO
BLOW UP HIS OWN HORN ON
THURSDAY.
>> WE ARE ROCKING.
WE ARE ROCKING.
KIM JONG-UN, KIM JONG-UN AND,
SLEEPING JOE, WE HAVE GREAT
HEALTHCARE PLANS COMING OUT THAT
THEY WEREN'T SAYING MERRY
CHRISTMAS BUT NOW THEY ARE
SAYING MERRY CHRISTMAS AGAIN.
AMERICA IS RESPECTED AGAIN.
I HAVE DELIVERED MORE THAN I
PROMISE.
GREG: OH MY GOD WHAT IS HE
GLOATING?
THE CARES.
HE SHOULD GLOAT.
THE RALLIES ALREADY GET THE GOOD
NEWS BUT THE MEDIA IGNORES.
IT TRUMP NEWS AND HE'S THE
ANCHOR.
OF COURSE, WHAT WERE THE OTHER
NEWS BUCKETS FULL OF?
>> THE LAWYER FIRST READING IS A
STEPPING UP HIS ATTACK.
>> I ALMOST FORGOT WHAT I WAS
GOING TO TALK ABOUT BUT OF
COURSE, I DIDN'T SPREAD IT
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE HE WAS VERY
GOOD AT.
THE MONEY TO STORMY DANIELS
DIDN'T WORK OR SILENCER.
>> IT'S NOT ILLEGAL FROM WHAT WE
KNOW BUT IT LOOKS BAD AND HAS
THE STENCH OF THE SWAMP.
THAT STENCH AFFECTS BOTH TRUMP
AND COHEN.
GREG: THESE NETWORKS WAS
OBSESSED WITH PORN THEY SHOULD
BE SPONSORED BY KLEENEX.
[LAUGHTER]
NOW IMAGINE AMERICA AS THE
WORLD'S GREATEST ALL-INCLUSIVE
RESORT WITH WATER SLIDES AND
PULL BARS AND CASINOS AND WHERE
IS THE MEDIA?
HIDING IN THE HOTEL ROOM
WATCHING TV AND IS STUCK ON THE
VIEW.
IT'S WEIRD IT'S LIKE THE MEDIA
CAN'T SEE THEMSELVES OR EVEN THE
OUTSIDE WORLD.
IT'S AS IF THEY'RE TRAPPED
LIVING IN SOME GIGANTIC
FOOTPRINT LEFT BY KING KONG
EXCEPT IT'S NOT KONG FOOTPRINT
AT ALL BUT IT'S TRUMPS.
[LAUGHTER]
AFTER HE STOMPED ON THEM IN 2016
AND SO THEY HAVE FOLLOWED IN AND
THEY CAN'T GET UP.
I FEAR THAT IF SOMEONE DOESN'T
PULL THEM ON A PLATTER THEY WILL
END UP EATING EACH OTHER ALIVE.
THAT SUCKS.
I HATE CANNIBALS.
THEY'RE SO FULL OF THEMSELVES.
[LAUGHTER]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
SHE IS A BRIGHT FIREFLIES TRY TO
CATCH HER AND PUT HER IN THE
JAR, AUTHOR AND TV HOST TO THE
DIET.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
HE HAS TACKLED MORE WILLS THAN
MICHAEL MOORE'S MISS SHOOTS.
THANK YOU, ACTOR DANIEL.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SHE IS BREATHY, SASSY AND HER
GAZE IS GLASSY, KAT SIMS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
AND HE KEEPS HIS PANTS UP WITH
AN ASTEROID BELT.
FORMER WWE SUPERSTAR AND MIGHT
MASSIVE SIDEKICK, TYRUS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: JEDEDIAH, ALL THIS CHAOS
GOING AROUND AND HE IS STILL
GETTING STUFF DONE.
HOW IS THIS POSSIBLE?
>> YEAH, THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE
ELECTED HIM TO DO.
HE WAS SAYING CRAZY STUFF AND
EVERYONE A KNOWLEDGE HE HAD THIS
CRAZY PAST BUT WE WERE LIKE, WE
WANT A GUY AND I DIDN'T VOTE FOR
HIM TO PUT UP RAND PAUL BUT MOST
PEOPLE WERE LIKE YOU WANT A GUY
TO GET THE JOB DONE.
IT'S HYSTERICAL WHEN YOU WATCH
THESE VIDEOS BECAUSE I THINK THE
MEDIA IS SO INVESTED IN HIS
DEMISE THAT THEY HAVE DECIDED
THAT THEY WENT ON RECORD AND
SAID THIS GUY WILL BE A BIG
FAILURE AND A BIG JOKE.
SO WHEN HE DOES WELL THEY LOOK
DUMB AND THEY LOOK LIKE THEY
WEREN'T PAYING ATTENTION AND
THEIR PREDICTIONS ARE WRONG SO
THERE INVESTED IN HIM PEELING
AND THEY DON'T CARE THAT MAY
MEAN THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
MAY SUFFER THAT YOUR PAYCHECKS
WILL BE LOWER AND THAT OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY MIGHT BE
THREATENED WAS FASCINATING TO
WATCH BECAUSE SPECIFICALLY WITH
THE PRISONERS THAT WERE BROUGHT
BACK THAT WAS A STORY THAT
EVERYONE ACROSS THE AISLE, BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE HAD TO COME
FORWARD AND ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS WAS A GOOD THING.
BUT THEY ARE SUFFERING WHEN YOU
WATCH THEM.
IT'S SO TRANSPARENT THAT IT LETS
EVERYBODY KNOW THAT EVERYONE HAS
BEEN SAYING THE MEDIA IS BIASED
AND THEY TELL YOU AND SHOW YOU
ON THEIR FACE.
GREG: AND YOU WANT TO SEE MY
IMPRESSION FOR RAND PAUL?
[LAUGHTER]
>> LISTEN, I STILL VOTED.
I GIVE HIM CREDIT WHERE CREDIT
IS DUE.
THIS GUY IS DOING A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS.
IT WAS A GREAT WEEK FOR HIM.
I'M PROUD TO HAVE HIM AS MY
PRESIDENT THIS WEEK AND I'LL SAY
THAT ANYTIME HE DOES SOMETHING
GOOD.
GREG: WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS WEEK AND OVERALL ANYTHING?
>> I THOUGHT THIS WAS A
FANTASTIC WEEK TO CELEBRATE
BEING AN AMERICAN.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT HOW HORRIBLE IT IS TO BE
AN AMERICAN AND I ALWAYS THINK,
REALLY?
WE ARE NOT THE ONES HOLDING
ANYONE PRISONER.
NO ONE IS BEING HELD AGAINST --
CRIMINALS ARE BEING HELD AND WE
ARE ALL FOR THAT, I THINK BUT
YOU KNOW,  DISAGREE WITH THE
GOVERNMENT WE GENERALLY LET YOU
WALK AROUND AND WE GIVE YOU TV
SHOWS AND WE MAKE YOU FAMOUS SO
THIS IS A GREAT WEEK FOR
EVERYONE WHO DOES IT DISAGREE
FOR THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T AGREE
WITH THE GOVERNMENT.
I'M HAPPY TO BE AMERICAN.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: KAT?
IN THE GREEN ROOM YOU SAID IF
YOU COULD VOTE FOR TRUMP 18
TIMES HE WOULD.
KAT: I VOTED FOR GARY JOHNSON.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: I KNOW YOU DID.
KAT:
.AT:
.[I:
.[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
>> SHE'S A PERMANENT GUEST ON
THE SHELF AND SHE GETS TREATED
WITH RESPECT.
I SEE.
[LAUGHTER]
KAT: CREDIT IS WHERE CREDIT IS
DUE.
IT SHOULDN'T BE HARD TO BE HAPPY
THAT PRISONERS ARE BACK IN THE
UNITED STATES FROM NORTH KOREA.
IT SHOULDN'T BE DIFFICULT TO BE
EXCITED ABOUT THAT AND OBVIOUSLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP DESERVES CREDIT.
I KNOW BECAUSE I CANNOT DO IT.
I TRIED.
GREG: YOU DO TRY TO THREE
PRISONERS.
KAT: BUT THEY NEVER REPLIED TO
MY E-MAILS.
I USE PLEASE AND THE CUTE
ENERGIES BUT FOR SOME REASON
THEY STAY THERE AND YOU GET
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THERE AND YOU
GOT TO GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR DOING
IT.
THE PEOPLE FOCUS ALL WEEKEND
SAYING THE WORLD WILL END
BECAUSE WERE NOT IN IRAN DEAL
ANYMORE AND I'VE NOTICED THAT
THEY SAID THE WORLD WOULD AND
WHEN HE CALLED KIM TO LITTLE
ROCK MAN AND THEY SAID THE WORLD
IS GOING AND WE GOT ELECTED IN
THE FIRST PLACE AND I KEEP
WAKING UP IN THE MORNING AND
EVERYTHING IS FINE SO I FEEL
LIKE MAYBE IT'S NOT.
GREG: I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
THERE'S A PATTERN THAT HE
CREATES CHAOS AND FROM CHAOS
GAMES BUT I DO PROTECT YOU WILL
GET LETTERS FROM INMATES
TOMORROW.
[LAUGHTER]
KAT: EVEN MORE.
GREG: DO YOU THINK DONALD
TRUMP'S PAST OF DEALING WITH
UNSEEMLY PEOPLE IN REAL ESTATE
AND STUFF AND MOB HELPED HIM?
TYRUS: YEAH, WASN'T HE DEALING
WITH A CRIMINAL TYRANT AND
CONTINUED?
YEAH, I IT TAKES A WHILE BECAUSE
SHEPHERDS DON'T GET IT DONE BUT
THE NORTH KOREA THING IS SUCH A
BIG THING AND IT SO HARD FOR THE
OTHER SIDE.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR ANYTHING.
WHEN THEY FINALLY TALKED ABOUT
WHERE THE PLACE WILL BE AT WHERE
THE MEETING WILL BE AT THEY WERE
LIKE SINGAPORE AND THEY WERE
LIKE TO THINK DON LEMON SAID
SINGAPORE LOOSELY TRANSLATED WAS
ASIAN RUSSIA.
THEY WERE TRYING ANYTHING THAT
ISN'T THAT SOME OF THE COMMON
FAVORITE KITCHEN SPOTLIGHT THE
TRYING ANYTHING TO LINK THE RULE
IN SOMETHING BUT HORRIBLE HOTELS
THERE AND I CAN'T BELIEVE HE
PICK THE PLACE.
THEY CAN'T GIVE IT TO HIM BUT I
UNDERSTAND WHY BECAUSE WE ALL
DONALD TRUMP IS A GUY THAT WE
ALL WENT TO SCHOOL WITH THAT HAD
THE NICE CAR AND HAD THE
PRETTIEST CONFERENCE AND WHEN HE
GETS A STRAIGHT A AND HE SAYS
IA'S THAT AND YOU SAY I HATE
THIS DUDE.
AND I FEEL LIKE THAT IS WHERE
CNN IS RENUMBERED EVERYTHING HE
DOES SOMETHING IT'S LIKE NOW.